why would i try to rap to myself in the
shower am i going too fast and panicking
and rhyme like a word with something
that doesn't isn't a word why do i do
that oh yeah yeah just a sound like a
rhyming just like yeah i'm just trying
to rhyme like death with and i'll say
schmidt you gotta reverse the cadence so
most people say the line they want to
say like yo i'm sipping on a liquid
death and uh schmidt
so what i do for freestyling on top is
to reverse that smack the wrapper down
with the rhyme tackles my lyrics are
sharp just like a pineapple because you
knew you wanted pineapple so you set up
the other one first exactly so you look
around the room and do it like that if
it's fiji don't say fiji first because
what if you can't pull out something
that rhymes with fiji on top right
it's already working i looked at like
smoke and i'm like you want to make a
joke i'm going to
just go with nick theo so you want to be
a hero like sneakers all about bleeker
and like it's a lot easier it's a lot
easier i'm basically going to be jack
harlow in a week
i'm going to be a great rapper
[Music]